hi guys welcome to the PhD office this
is where I work it looks pretty bad that
wall isn't representative I could show
you that but you know I'm a bit
sensitive to the fact they work with
other people and they might not walk all
their stuff on camera but this is where
I work I've moved on my video equipment
in here because I've been doing a lot of
shooting on campus specifically for the
chapel choirs debut album I was doing
the artwork and photography for that
which is coming at them another she's
very exciting but it means that I'm now
gonna be vlogging here for the
foreseeable future so you know I'll see
if I can tart out that wall I'm still
getting used to the idea of only talking
about my life which is something and
inviting my life I mean not the PhD and
not books which is the other two series
I'm kind of doing in parallel with this
you know it's it's something and
particularly when you get quite far
along into your thesis it slightly takes
over your life and I think series like
this is really important for me because
it reminds me that there are other
things to life but you know I can
indulge myself in other activities you
know just something something's going to
the movies like just because it doesn't
directly help either my youtube channel
my thesis doesn't mean it's a bad thing
to do just to quickly mention I mean a
big thing that's happened to me recently
was went to Vienna if you didn't see
I've logged that's see that's a use for
that wall I'll put I'll put video stuff
up here so yeah Wednesday Fiona with Tom
and presenting my work just great and I
plan having some really good meetings
and stuff and my PhD supervisors
recently and some great work so the next
PhD watch should be great hard to talk
about P V in that and then the other
stuff is a lot of singing because terms
back and we're out to this album coming
out which um I probably end up putting a
video actually like a music video
maybe one the track where I'm singing a
solo in possibly on this channel was
like a primary for it so you'll see more
about that and the other thing that's
going on which is stuff that's happening
in the future is there's lots of
exciting video collaborations coming up
like I there's a good four or five
projects that are really really exciting
happening a little bit in the future but
I'm sort of organizing other people now
and can't wait to show you guys some of
the stuff the crash course this year
isn't gonna be just me let's put it like
that it's going to
me and another guy doing a crash course
on a specialist subject now as I
mentioned I'm finding it difficult to
sort of come up with things to talk
about in these vlogs because I'm so used
to just talking about my PhD so I asked
you guys on Twitter I ran a poll asking
what I should talk about and the winner
by a small margin
was recommending you videos and articles
that I've watched the read and I think
you should read or watch good Brian this
is really bad when I actually think
about it like that I'd love you to do is
go away and either read or watch these
things come back or you've already
watched them I'll read them come back
and comment and fight me in the comments
about whether you think I'm wrong for
loving it or if you agree not fighting
me fight me in a loving way first of all
three articles that I think you should
read first up one which is a quite a
long one but I found recently that was a
very good one which was about the
scientific journey to fill in the part
of the world's geological map before
Pangaea so working out you know the fact
that continents tripped all over the
world they coalesced to form a
supercontinent called Pangaea and they
separate split apart and the Mesozoic
era and then we have the current
configuration but before that there was
you know others things happened and this
article goes through the science of what
this team of scientists did to pick
apart that puzzle and reconstruct what
the world look like and yeah it's very
interesting you know kind of like a meta
academia thing something I found by
reddit which was basically who's
downloading pirated papers because most
scientific journals these days you know
published scientific research in a paper
those papers go in scientific journals
and more often than not those journals
put paywalls up so you can't nobody you
know the public can access these
articles which is all this year in
itself as an academic at university the
university pays a license so we don't
have to pay for journals I can just log
into why they online or nature or
science whatever and I can see it but
not everyone has that opportunity and
this article asks the question about
who's downloading them you know the
pirated version because there's a whole
infrastructure for people downloading
pirated scientific papers the answer is
basically everybody but it's a bit more
interesting that so that's one to read
next though I'm gonna recommend you
three documentaries or documentary
series to watch which I think are like
the pinnacle of my interests like
literally the best things ever if you
want to get me as a person watch
these three first that Fermat's Last
Theorem this is an incredible
documentary by the BBC by Simon Singh
who was a read a book about this and as
the title suggests it's about the this
famous theorem that pierre de firma came
up with which is a number theory theorem
and it's an hour-long documentary about
a guy called Andrew Wiles who proved
this this theory in a way that this
mathematician from the 18th century
could never have predicted and it's a
really interesting look at house how
mathematical research works why people
get really involved in mathematics you
know an emotional level the start of it
is kind of unforgettable as a
documentary talking to miles about the
moment he cracked it and and also gives
you a little bit of a primer to this
aspect the number theory but it's not
technical at all but yes
definitely watch it secondly one that
appeals to the filmmaking side of me
basically my favorite movie studio is
Pixar and I'm sure that's not a very
controversial statement lots of people
love Pixar but what lot of people don't
realize is that Pixar has really really
interesting
Genesis and a story behind how it came
into being so the Pixar story is that as
a feature-length documentary which
follows the history of the studio which
basically means it follows a guy called
John Lasseter
who was this utterly brilliant animator
who started out working at Disney and I
spotted a little bit of it for he was
fired from Disney because he proposed
these 3d computer animation and by
complete bunch of luck basically he
happened across a bunch of guys who were
working on 3d animation but from a
technical perspective not from an
artistic perspective they got together
and they ended up making Toy Story which
you might have heard of and the studio
then went on to basically redefine how
we look at animated films and kind of
reshaped modern American cinema and it's
a really really interesting story
I think it's available on Netflix at
least it's in some countries if not it's
available elsewhere then lastly for the
documentaries that I feel like really
define me as a BBC documentary another
one which is a multi-part documentary I
think they're for hour-long pieces
called the race to space and that's
about the Americans and the Soviets
trying to first get a get the hands of
rockets and how they were divvying up
the rocket resources of Nazi Germany
which is a really interesting story in
itself and then get the satellite space
then get a man in space they
get a man on the moon now another people
know the American side of things
specifically the moon landing stuff but
a lot of people don't know just how
amazing the Soviets were in particular
their chief designer guy called Sergei
Korolev who was just unbelievable and
him in front of on brown it's a little
bit of an example of great man history
these two guys who on the Soviet and
American side respectively just to find
the Cold War race to space and it's a
really really well made documentary
series it's like a retelling of events
it's like a dramatization and it's just
excellent then lastly I just thought it
recommends some YouTube channels which
have got some fantastic videos in that
I've basically become addicted to um
first of all what I've talked about
before every painting that's every frame
a painting and I'm not rushing mum I'm
always used to tell me that I burbled I
just kind of talked and like it's the
fella in my mouth my dad will call it
verbal diarrhea every frame a painting
looks at cinematography and editing and
some incredibly well-made video essays
I'll put one up here I'd recommend you
look at the one on Jackie Chan on
another one an Edgar Wright and another
one on Michael Bay and have super
insightful and then another filmmaking
channel this one has more of an emphasis
on cinematography and directing I'd say
it's channel Criswell another one up
here I really recommend you watch his
video on use of color in the film
because it's one of the most poetic and
informative pieces of entertainment on
YouTube it's just it's just amazing I
love there's several of these channels I
could recommend a whole heap of
filmmaking channels but I think those
two are the best at the moment next
another channel which is a guest bit
more scientific like the race to space
side of me called the engineering guy
this is a professor at the University of
Illinois I want to say and he basically
produces videos on things that you
didn't think he'd be interested about
for example like the design of the
aluminium beverage can the aluminium not
the aluminum and it's just you never
thought you'd watch 10-15 minute video
on how cans are designed but it's super
interesting a channel which I've only
just heard about and I've really waiting
for the next video to come out it's
called the history buffs this is a
channel that combines my love history
and my love of films and it basically
takes historical films like Waterloo and
the deus gladiator stuff like that and
does a historical analysis and sees how
they are and uses it to explore
different themes and how we portray
history and it's not quite as
professional as some of the other ones
some the filmmaking channels in terms of
its analysis but I really like it it's
really good one for the musicians out
there you've probably already heard of
this but just in case you haven't
there's an amazing channel called
postmodern jukebox which takes like
modern and when I say modern I mean like
90s in 2000 2010 kind of songs but
redoes them in styles from the 1920s the
1960s like that one I really hope I
remember to put these in in post and
they're really really really well made
and they're incredibly talented the
musicians that they get they rotate in a
cast of people yeah go listen you're
welcome if you didn't know about them
and then lastly another filmmaking one
it's almost like I do more video making
than PhD isn't it another channel which
is called red letter media red letter
media do a variety of things they're
best known for the their reviews of the
Star Wars prequels which if you haven't
seen and you like films go and watch
them because they eviscerate the
prequels in the most glorious way it's
so cathartic and it's a great way to
learn about film theory to see what
movies do wrong what movies do right my
particular favorite at the moment is a
series called best of the worst where
they take three crappy VHS tapes from
the 80s and 90s and watch them and then
try and decide which one of them was the
best which is difficult because it's
like comparing three turds in cinematic
terms yeah I really really like it so
yeah links to all those would be down
there hopefully they'll all fit in the
pants and I hope that this was
interesting it's the first video that
I've done it's basically exclusively
just recommending things because I'm
struggling to think about things that
aren't my favorite do you that I can
talk about if you know of any
documentaries that you think I'd enjoy
based on my recommendations please put
it in the comments and come fight me if
you think that my recommendations are
trash and I'll be seeing you quite soon
when I may be doing the PhD watch videos
and the book club which will be on Game
of Thrones
some of us on fire and we'll also be
revealing this new plan for the book
club where we're going to be reading a
book together so i'm reaiiy mac chily
really really excited there's so much
great stuff going on the moment probably
to get back to write my thesis though
yes a one
see it see yourself out we this is a
completely different setting another
wonderful difference in my setting that
we do in order to talk this is by
Jonathan Duff who is a contemporary
composer he's still alive unusually for
some of the composing here's his very
life I have years it's just as I'm
giving people const attitudes and these
are coping so workshop some things like
stress busting exam stress busting
procrastination perfectionism the kind
of common